[Music]
on this saturday night dealing with
delays at canada's airports
ottawa suspends random covet 19 testing
for some passengers this is like
tinkering at best will it make a
difference demanding gun control
thousands rally across the u.s for
firearms reform as uvalde's school
district police chief defends his delay
in confronting a mass shooter he said
that was a conscious decision canada's
commitments what prime minister trudeau
agreed to at the summit of the americas
and discovering a different sound an
alberta program helps trans and gender
diverse people find their voice i have
more tools to be able to make my voice
sound more like darker or more masculine
global national
reporting tonight
eric sorensen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with breaking news out of
ottawa where parliament hill has
reopened after a threat investigation
shut down the area for hours a public
safety source tells global news police
received information that raised
concerns about possible credible threats
from explosives near parliament hill
mps and senators were told to shelter in
place during the investigation multiple
sources say there have been arrests it's
not clear how many people or why ottawa
police say now the incident is over just
four months ago protesters occupied the
streets around parliament hill for
several weeks
as of today fully vaccinated travelers
arriving at canada's airports will no
longer face mandatory random covet 19
testing the federal government says it's
a temporary move to help eliminate the
bottlenecks at major airports across the
country but as morgan campbell reports
critics say more needs to be done
even if you don't travel it's likely you
have seen social media footage or heard
of long lineups and delays at major
airports across canada particularly
pearson international airports i'm here
four hours prior to my departure but
better you know
early than sorry friday the federal
government suspended randomized testing
of fully vaccinated air passengers from
saturday until july first to reduce wait
times but there is concern the move
won't actually alleviate much of the
pressure felt here at canada's largest
airports in may nearly half a million
passengers faced delays on returning
international flights here at pearson
which equates to about half of all
arrivals from abroad it doesn't really
seem to me to to control anything the
big the big issue the big slowdown has
been the security and the customs and
this doesn't have to do anything to do
with either one of those as of july 1st
unvaccinated travelers will be tested
off-site which could cause more delays
but the feds still believe randomized
testing is important and some experts
agree and there obviously has to be a
balance of acquiring that information
and of course not inconveniencing the
general population the federal
government has also hired more than 860
screening officers across the country
the cbsa has also added more staff
meanwhile canada's travel industry has
been lobbying the federal government
and its u.s counterparts to remove
testing on both sides of the border
saying such measures are having a
negative impact on tourism and keeping
international visitors away it is
possible canada could see an influx of
travelers from the u.s as the biden
administration begins dropping
pre-departure tests for people flying
into america most of the people are kind
of
scared of getting tested
and then waiting for the results people
have been waiting for this
u.s restrictions will be lifted sunday
morgan campbell global news pearson
international airport
ontario is lifting nearly all of its
remaining covert 19 mask mandates today
people are no longer required to wear
masks on public transit and in most
health care settings many hospitals
across the province are keeping the
rules in place for visitors and staff
mass mandates will also remain in
ontario's long-term care and retirement
homes
public health officials in toronto are
stepping up efforts to stop monkey pox
from spreading the city will hold
vaccination clinics for high risk
individuals starting tomorrow the
program will offer protection to those
who've had close contact with known
cases and those at higher risk of being
exposed to the virus employees of local
bath houses will be immunized first
several clinics will follow in the
coming weeks there are now 11 confirmed
cases in toronto and more than 100
across the country
hundreds of thousands of americans are
demanding new gun laws as march for our
lives rallies were held from coast to
coast the first march for our lives was
held four years ago after the mass
shooting at a high school in parkland
florida as jennifer johnson reports the
latest massacres in buffalo and uvalde
have activists demanding action on gun
control again
from brooklyn new york to washington d.c
and dozens of other cities across
america hundreds of thousands of
protesters sent one clear message to
lawmakers your inaction is killing
americans this is not a political issue
this is a moral issue
nowhere in the
constitution is unrestricted access to
weapons of war a guaranteed right
in parkland florida where high school
students first started this movement
there were fiery speeches years after
the massacre there mass shootings in the
u.s continue to leave communities
shattered people say that most movements
take a long time until change is made
but 10 years since the sandy hook
shooting and four years since the
parkland shooting seems like a pretty
long damn time to me
the yeas are 223.
this week the house passed bills that
would raise the age to buy a
semi-automatic gun to 21 ban
high-capacity magazines and allow judges
to confiscate weapons from anyone deemed
dangerous but that package has little
chance of passing the senate where 10
republicans would have to join democrats
a different bipartisan bill is now being
worked on i'm not interested in doing
something unless that something is going
to save lives there have already been
over 250 mass shootings in america so
far this year yet no major federal gun
control legislation has passed congress
since 1994. polls show most americans
have had enough including teachers in
texas over the course of the year we
will be expected to interrupt our school
day to conduct lockdown drills to show
the children what it will feel like to
be hunted by a gunman intent on
murdering them gun control advocates vow
to keep the pressure on lawmakers and
not allow the passage of time to lead to
nothing getting passed in congress again
activists hope after so much bloodshed
in america something will finally change
jennifer johnson global news washington
on the heels of today's rallies the
police chief of the school district in
uvalde texas is speaking publicly for
the first time pete arredondo told the
texas tribune he didn't have his police
radios because he thought they would
slow him down and he needed both hands
free
he said that was a conscious decision he
rushed in there put both of his hands on
his gun because he was taught that that
was the
um that was the most accurate way to
attack the the shooter if he ran into
him
when the police chief did locate the
shooter in a classroom he said the door
was locked and he had to try dozens of
keys before he was able to get in and
rescue the children who were still alive
one hour and 17 minutes after the
shooting began
prime minister justin trudeau is
returning to ottawa with some new
agreements from the summit of the
americas trudeau spent the week in los
angeles meeting his hemispheric
counterparts on issues like climate
change and irregular migration
david aiken is traveling with the prime
minister
david what happened
when the summit of the americas opened
on wednesday it opened with a
controversy over its guest list cuba
venezuela and nicaragua were not invited
and mexico sat it out in solidarity with
those other three there had been
concerns that without mexico the summit
host u.s president joe biden would have
trouble getting what he wanted in los
angeles a deal on irregular migration
even as the summit opened a caravan of
thousands of migrants were tramping
across mexico towards the u.s border but
by week's end biden got what he wanted
the leaders on this stage are joining
together
to make what and as a voice an overused
phrase in international relations and
public life to make a historic
commitment because it is a historic
commitment we're about to make canada
signed on to the los angeles declaration
on migration and protection promising to
take in more refugees from the americas
and fund some border management projects
in central america and the caribbean
there are no easy answers on this this
is a deep complex problem that quite
frankly adds itself to a range of
problems around the world trudeau says
the declaration is important because 20
countries signed on to it what was
really important with the work done
this week and leading up to this week
was the opening of a conversation with
hemispheric partners trudeau also argued
that a multilateral approach including
face-to-face conversations between
leaders at international summits is
vital to helping solve global problems
the pandemic and climate change have
underlined for all of us just how small
the world is and how what happens
elsewhere matters deeply not just us as
governments but to our citizens also
while in la trudeau inked a new climate
partnership with california governor
gavin newsom it's one that will among
other things see the two jurisdictions
work together to find ways to reduce
increasingly destructive wildfires this
los angeles summit was just the first of
what could be a very busy month for
justin trudeau on the international
summit circuit by the end of the month
commonwealth leaders meet in rwanda g7
leaders meet in germany and nato leaders
have a key meeting in spain and the
canadian prime minister is expected to
be at all of those meetings david aiken
global news los angeles
around the world countries are under
mounting pressure to take urgent action
to combat climate change u.s president
joe biden aims to slash his country's
carbon emissions in half by 2030. that
means moving towards cleaner energy more
quickly how does canada factor in our
ottawa bureau chief mercedes stephenson
sat down with the u.s ambassador to
canada mercedes david cohen's recent
comments about canadian energy have
sparked some controversy
eric u.s ambassador david cohen has been
feeling a bit of diplomatic heat after
he made comments about alberta's oil and
gas sector that were not met with fond
feelings from that province's government
when it comes to weaning off russian oil
over the conflict in ukraine and the
rising price of gas at the pumps some
hope the u.s might look to alberta as a
solution but cohen was quoted in late
may in the national post saying the u.s
was quote not really in the market to
expand oil and gas links to canada
alberta's energy minister called the
comments ill-informed and unproductive i
asked ambassador cohen about his
statements and he took a more open tone
but made it clear that fighting climate
change is still a priority for president
biden we'd always be interested in more
oil and gas
from alberta or from anywhere else
but
we have to let's go and make let's go
and define our terms cohen doesn't agree
that alberta's help would necessarily
solve consumer pain at the pumps and he
emphasized the us's commitment to
looking for new clean energy sources
as a
policy objective in the energy space
we have to be very careful about making
major investments
tens of billions of dollars of
investments that will produce more
fossil fuels
five years from now 10 years from now 20
years from now that will increase
emissions and make it difficult or
impossible to achieve the climate change
targets that we need to achieve
another hot topic for the canada u.s
relationship is defense spending and
while the ambassador did not overtly
criticize the canadian government on
this he did indicate that the u.s was
disappointed in the gap between the
trudeau government's public rhetoric on
what they were going to spend on the
military compared to what showed up in
the budget and he noted that canada is
still a ways off from reaching that nato
2 spending target canada though in
making those assessments did
pledge in the whale's commitments to
move its defense spending um to two
percent of gdp
um this spending does not do that
there's a report that was released
this week that
predicts that on its current trajectory
canada won't get to two percent over
over a five-year period but the report
notes that
canada will move closer to the two
percent level i also asked the
ambassador about the biggest threats to
democracy in both canada and the united
states we'll have more on the west block
on sunday eric
mercedes stevenson in ottawa for us
tonight thank you mercedes
coming up why people who experienced
hate incidents during the pandemic
rarely reported them
as we've reported many times during the
pandemic hate crimes are on the rise now
a new survey confirms it and that many
people say they didn't bother reporting
the incidents bc's human rights
commissioner says it's time for better
strategies to fight hate camille
caramalli has more it's been more than
two years since trixie ling's brush with
anti-asian hate but even now it's tough
to forget i see this white man
approaching me and we
walked past each other he turned around
he spat on my face
now a survey conducted by the bc office
of the human rights commissioner shows
people have experienced more hate during
the pandemic but few have reported it
the results showed 35 percent of people
surveyed experienced witnessed or were
affected by hate during the pandemic of
those more than half felt there was a
rise of hate incidents because people
were blaming certain groups for the
pandemic and out of all those who
experienced hate incidents 72 percent
did not report it and 68 believed
reporting it would not make a difference
we know that some people don't feel that
police are able to provide them
with a support or will treat them fairly
in that process particularly racialized
people might feel that way you chose to
report this to police so why did you
choose to speak up i really felt the
need if i don't do anything he'll do
this to someone else ling says only to
find out her case had been dropped by
police six months after she had reported
it oh that made me feel really angry
discouraged and angry because there's
just no accountability police say that's
likely one of the reasons why victims
don't report these incidents a lack of
results but even if reporting it doesn't
lead to an arrest police say it still
provides other benefits we need to hear
about it so we can properly track it and
so we can understand what's happening in
the community and so that we can
properly respond to the community's
needs bc's human rights commissioner
says the next step is to put forward
recommendations by next year to help
build trust between victims of hate and
the institutions that might be able to
stop it kamel karamali global news
still ahead the beef with some new
health canada food labeling requirements
in the coming weeks you may see new
labels on packages of ground meat at the
grocery store health canada says
nutrition symbols will be required on
the front of packages for foods high in
sodium sugars or saturated fat many
products will be exempt but ground meats
are not one of them and as troy charles
reports it's left some in the meat
industry scratching their heads
soon any food that contains 15 percent
of your recommended daily intake of
sodium sugars and saturated fat will be
slapped with a front of package
nutrition symbol
for some the inclusion of ground meats
which are high in saturated fat doesn't
add up canada would be the only one
that had a single ingredient product
that had this warning just
makes it make
less and less sense and we think the
government and the minister of health
should reconsider 50 of beef consumed in
canada is ground with inflation a major
issue at the grocery store ground meat
prices have remained more stable than
others when you think about protein for
affordability you're basically
discouraging canadians
from eating these products that are
still relatively affordable compared to
other cuts so you have to wonder whether
or not it's the right time to do this
charlemagne added these labels can be a
motivating factor for industry to
innovate to force them to research and
make better products that would have had
too much sodium fats and sugar but what
do you do with ground beef what do you
do with ground pork there's nothing else
you can do
it's a natural single ingredient product
charlevoix feels ground meats should be
exempt from the label in a statement
health canada says that exemptions occur
when there is evidence that the food
provides a protective effect on health
ground beef is one of the most
affordable
nutrient packed products that can help
with that iron deficiency zinc vitamin
b12 oh and by the way a great source of
protein lee and charlevoix are calling
on federal agencies to reconsider health
canada says they are not warning labels
but intended to reduce health risks as
canadians intake of saturated fats
remains above recommended limits
troy charles global news
next the alberta program speaking up for
trans and gender diverse people
[Applause]
after two years of covet 19 restrictions
thousands packed the streets of rome
today for the return of the city's pride
parade this year's slogan we're back to
make noise a tribute to the late gay
icon rafael cara after years of little
to no government support rome's mayor
marched in today's parade a move
described by organizers as very
encouraging
in alberta a remarkable program is
helping trans and gender diverse people
find the voice that matches how they see
themselves it's seeing a big jump in
referrals and as sooling gold reports
those in the program say it makes them
feel more comfortable and confident
parker pattier says a trip through the
drive-thru was once a source of stress
if i'm having a bad day and somebody
says okay ma'am pull up to the window
like it feels really deflating parker
identifies as a non-binary transgender
person when they started transitioning a
few years ago i
realized that the things i was doing to
change how i looked and to change how i
sounded was bringing me a lot of
euphoria with my gender and so that was
when i realized like how much happier i
could be a doctor referred parker to the
voice and resonance program at the glen
rose rehabilitation hospital
dr teresa hardy was the u of a's first
practitioner and researcher of gender
voice training she helps clients set
goals and work towards the voice they
want not necessarily feminine or
masculine it's like learning a musical
instrument because we're learning to use
the voice or the instrument in a
different way when i saw
you know who i was going to be working
with and the level of expertise that she
had it really did surprise me that there
was someone who cared enough like that
the therapy is publicly funded but the
wait time is long over the past decade
referrals have increased from five per
year to more than five per month it took
parker three and a half years to get in
but it was worth it i have more tools to
be able to make my voice sound more like
darker or more masculine at will kind of
thing you know and so it's very
freeing i guess dr hardy says it's
rewarding to help people sound more like
themselves and navigate a sometimes
difficult society i've heard from
numerous clients that
doing this work kind of makes them feel
like they have a bit of a shield against
some of that marginalization or makes
them feel a bit safer as they interact
with the world and for some people it
can even be life-saving sue lingo global
news
and that's global national for this
saturday i'm eric sorenson tonight's
york canada is vancouver's girl in a
wetsuit statue the landmark turned 50
this weekend it was unveiled in stanley
park in 1972. we love seeing your canada
please keep sending your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching chris galas will be
here tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]
you